no control hi I'm the wrong person to
ask about LinkedIn and Facebook because
um i don't get it i get 10 of these
things a day Bob Smith would like to be
your friend who the hell are you what
why do you want to be my friend I I
don't know you I don't get it I can see
for a college kid you know wanting to
show how many friends he has I mean you
know there are there are great features
you announced that you're getting
married you invite people to a party you
look for someone with expertise to help
you with a project there there are
genuine uses but I've heard the cynics
say it's just all about ego massage
there is no privacy now there is no
privacy now one time I reviewed a
project a product called future phone it
was a service that let you make free
international calls free you would pick
up your phone you dial an access number
in Iowa and say put in the country code
and phone number and presto you could
talk as long as you want overseas for
free and I loved it it was great but my
readers went crazy they could not figure
out how are they making money and
finally on the response area of the
website one reader said I know it's a
privacy scam they're listening in to our
phone calls and I'm like and what and
he's like well like if we're going to
buy a stock they would they would know
in advance and they could buy it up and
I'm like dude if you're going to be
paranoid at least be sensible about your
paranoia look if you are worried about
privacy then how do you know visa is not
at this moment looking for your
statements going oh my god another
renewal of the playboy apologies how do
you know verizon is not right now
looking for your statements going can
you believe this guy he's got three
girlfriends I mean you don't know you
have no privacy that what you buy at the
grocery store on your on your loyalty
card I mean they know everything about
you and frankly if you think that anyone
is that interested in the mundane
details of your life your self
aggrandizing so a you have no privacy
now be it's only going to get worse and
see you really not that interesting
you